[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم انا ميسون واهد
وهذه العربيه
360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
نبدا مع العناوين
جوني رمادي
وروسيا تواجه تحديين نهر باخمت والتلال في
محيطها
بعد نفي واشنطن تحرير اموال ايرانيه مقابل
رهائنها ايران تتراجع وتقول ان تفاصيل
جاهزه وينقصها الرغبه
سعيا لتجنب تاثير
تتحرك لضمان ودائع بنك سيليكون فالي ولندن
تحاول النجاه بفرعها
لدينا ايضا في 360
فازت او لم تفز الاوسكار يحتفي بافلام
اعاده الجمهور بعد ازمه كورونا وكاتب
لعشاه تسعى لنجمه نادره ثالثه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن مسؤولين
امريكيين تاكيدهم بان هناك خلافات بين
اداره بيض واوكرانيا خلف الكواليس حول
اداره كيف للحرب وذكرت الصحيفه ان
الولايات المتحده نصحت اوكرانيا بالتخلي
عن بخمه الاستنزافها الموارد لكنك رفضت
ذلك معتبره ان التخلي عن باخمت سيؤدي
لخساره دانيت باكملها واشار مسؤولون
امريكيون الى ان واشنطن ترى ان معركه
طباخمت ستحد من قدره اوكرانيا علشان هجوم
مضاده الصحيفه اشارت كذلك الى ان واشنطن
ابلغت اوكرانيا ان مهاجمتها للقرم ستعقد
فرص الحل لكن اوكرانيا تجاهلت نصائح
واشنطن العسكريه ولم يظهر الرئيس
الاوكراني
كافيا للدعم العسكري الامريكي كما اشارت
بوليتيكو نقلا عن مشرعين امريكيين ان هناك
انقساما داخل اداره بايدن حاليا حول
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا في هذه
الفتره المقبله
لكن السؤال مشاهدينا الان ما هو هدف
الاوكرانيين من المعركه في باختموت لماذا
كل هذا الاصرار على الدفاع عن المدينه رغم
الكلفه الباهظه لواء الهجوم الجوي
الاوكرانيه الثمانين الذي يجهز لهجوم
المضاد على وتاكد ان الهدف هو استنزاف
الروس حتى الرمق الاخير ولد الجنود فكره
واضحه بانه مقابل كل جندي اوكراني يسقط
سريعا في المعركه يسقط سبعه من الجنود
الروسي ويعتقد الجنود الاوكرانيون ان هذه
المعركه مهما كانت نتيجتها سيكون لها
تاثير معنوي مدمر على الجنود الروس فيما
سيلي من معارك
من واشنطن ينضم الى مراسل العربيه حسين
الطوضح حسين اهلا بك معنا الى اي حد حقيقه
هناك خلافات بين اداره بايدن وبين
اوكرانيا
تحيه لك ميسون نحن عندما ننظر الى هذا
الامر نعتمد على البيانات الرسميه التي
تصدرها الاداره الامريكيه يمكننا نتحدث عن
البيت الابيض او عن وزاره الخارجيه او حتى
عن البانتاجون كل هذه البيانات حتى الان
تشدد على وقوف الولايات المتحده الى جانب
اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن سيادتها وهناك
بيانات دائما تتحدث عن اتصالات بين وزير
الدفاع
الامن القومي وحتى رئيس الاركان الامريكي
نظرائهم الاوكرانيين يؤكدون فيها على
الدعم المستمر للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا
ليس هناك اي مؤشرات
لاختلاف وخاصه بموضوع بخموت وبموضوع
التكتيكات العسكريه وموضوع بان رئيس
لينسكي مصر على استرجاع القرب اليس هناك
من مؤشرات بان الولايات المتحده ممتعده من
تمسك الرئيسكي بهذه الاستراتيجيه وبهذه
المطالب
بالنسبه لموضوع بخمه تحديدا ميسون
الامريكيون يقولون انهم دائما
يتبعون ما يريده او يتفقون مع ما يريده ما
يحتاجه
الاوكرانيون وهم يقدمون لهم الدعم
ويقدمونهم المعدات العسكريه اللازمه لكل
مرحله ولكن هم لا يتدخلون بما يريده
الاوكرانيون في ارض المعركه لانهم يتركون
الامر لهم لانهم هم الذين على الارض
بالنسبه الاوكرانيين الان يرون بان محمود
كما قرانا في تحليلات عسكريه عده بان
مخبوط الان هي مصيده لقوات فاجنر من خلال
هذه المصير يقتلون عددا كبيرا منهم
ويتوقعون انهم مع انتهاء هذه المعركه لن
تستطيع قوات
هجوما لذلك الامريكيون راينا انهم لا
ينتقدون كثيرا الاوكرانيين بهذا المساله
لانهم يدركون جيدا لا يصرحون بانهم هم على
الارض وهم يقدرون احتياجاتهم على الارض
وهم من يقدرون سير المعارك تصريحات كثيره
في هذا المجال بالنسبه لموضوع الاسلحه
الاوكرانيين يطال الاسلحه هذه منذ بدايه
الحرب العام الماضي كان الاوكرانيون دائما
يطالبون بالمزيد من الاسلحه لانهم يحتاجون
الى المزيد من الذخائر لكي يصدوا الهجمات
الروسيه ولكي يشنوا هجمات مضاده الان هناك
هناك تحليلات تتحدث عن موضوع القرم تحديدا
بان الامريكيين كانوا وفق هذه التحليلات
دائما ميسون كانوا يفضلون لا يكون هناك
هجوم على القرب لكي يكون موضوع القرن ورقه
ضغط لجلب روسيا الى طاوله المفاوضات هذا
ما كان نقرا ونسمع نور ولكن ان نتحدث عن
خلاف امريكي
اوكراني كما اشارت اليه بوليتيكو هذا امر
يعني بحسب البيانات الرسميه هو غير واضح
كثيرا بحسب البيانات الرسميه الامريكيه
التي تتحدث عن الدعم المستمر من الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا شكرا لك من واشنطن
زميلنا مراسل العربيه حسين الطاوود على كل
هذه التوضيحات
[موسيقى]
قوات فجن المشاهدينا تواصل تقدمها داخل
مدينه بخموت من جهه الشرق بحسب قاده
ميدانيين روس ونهر ضيق يفصل بين الجانبين
الروسي والاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه تحاول
عبور من المناطق الشرقيه للمدينه التي
تسيطر عليها لمواصله التقدم واكمال
التطويق المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه هدمت
جسورا رئيسيه فوق النهر في مسعد لاعاقه
التقدم الروسي الى قلب باخت كما دفعت
بالمزيد من التعزيزات للجبهات الغربيه من
النهر وغير مره لجات القوات الاوكرانيه
خلال هذه الحرب لتفجير الجسور لكن الجيش
الروسي دائما ما وجد حلا في الجسور
العائمه لتلافي معضله الانتقال بين ضفاف
الانهار في اوكرانيا لكن السؤال الان ماذا
بعد
التقارير تشير الى ان قوات فاجنر والقوات
الروسيه ستستمر في الاندفاع غربا وستكون
خطوتها التاليه
توجه نحو بلده كوستانتيكيبا او التقدم الى
سلوفيا ومحاوله مسك الاراضي لكن بحسب
محللين سيعتمد التقدم الروسي على تسويه كل
المباني التي تواجه القوات بالارض ومحاوله
منع الهجمات الاوكرانيه المضاده ان حصل
هذا ما هي خيارات اوكرانيا اولا قد تلجا
اوكرانيا للقيام بانسحاب تكتيكي
والاستعداد لشن هجوم المضاد خلال الاسابيع
المقبله او قد تلجا لخيار اخر وهو تعزيز
السيطره على قريه خراموف وتشيسافيار على
الجانب الغربي من باخموت وهي مواقع مرتفعه
يمكن استغلالها للهجوم على اي قوات روسيه
تحاول الاقتراب من المنطقه لنتابع كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل ينضم الى من عمان
اللواء محمد ثلجي المحلل العسكري حضره
اللواء اهلا بك معنا ما هي الصعوبات التي
ستواجهها روسيا لعبور هذا النهر الذي
تحاول عبوره من اجل السيطره على
مساء الخير اخت ميسون ومساء الخير للاخوه
المشاهدين حقيقه يعني عمليات عبور الانهر
هي من العمليات المركبه والمعقده وهي تاتي
ضمن العمليات العسكريه الخاصه التي تجيها
القوات العسكريه في اماكن محدده وفي اماكن
معينه هذه العمليه عاده ما تتطلب الكثير
من التخطيط والكثير من التحضير والكثير
ايضا من الدقه في التنفيذ واختيار
التوقيتات بدقه وبعنايه وبعنايه فائقه جدا
ولكن ضمن هذه المعركه والتي يبدو سيدتي
بان معركه باخموت قد اختصرت الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه في هذه المدينه وفي
محيط هذه المدينه نظرا لما تحتل هذه
المدينه من اهميه رمزيه اصبحت لك الى
الطرفين هذا النهر الذي يقسم المدينه الى
الى قسمين ويحتل تحتل قوات فاغنر الجزء
الشرقي وما زالت القوات الاوكرانيه تتمترس
يعني في الجزء الغربي ولا زال هذا النهر
يشكل يعني حاجزا طبيعيا ربما صعبا على
القوات الروسيه في ان تجتازه في الوقت
الحاضر نظرا لقوه الدفاعات الموجوده على
الطرف الغربي وهذا يتاتى من قوه صمود
القوات الاوكرانيه لغايه هذه اللحظه وعدم
قوه قدره قوات فاجنر وقوات المشاه الروسيه
من اجتياز هذا النار فيما قررت القوات
الروسيه سيدتي اجتياز هذا النهر نعم يعني
اعذرني ولكن هناك ايضا موضوع مهم جدا
البعض يرى بانه التكتيك الاوكراني هو
استنزاف روسيا في باخموت الى اي حد هذا
الاستنزاف يجدي نفعا وخاصه ايضا اوكرانيا
تدفع اسماء باهظه في بخموت
سيدتي نعم اتفق معك تماما يعني هذه
العمليه هذه المعركه التي اعتقد الكثير
بانها ستاخذ عده اسابيع فقط لاحتلال ولكن
هذه المعركه معركه باكموت وايل المعركه
الاطول والاكثر دمويه خلال الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه والتي لا زالت تروح
مكانها لسبعه اشهر متواصله الاوكران هنالك
عوامل عديده من ضمنها خمس عوامل وجزها
يعني
يبرر فيها الاوكرانيين صمودهم
وتمتين دفاعاتهم في منطقه باك موت للاسباب
التاليه اولا يريد الاوكرانيين ان تكون
اباك نموذجا للدفاع والتصدي ضد القوات
الروسيه هي في هذه المرحله وهذا من باب
يعني من ياتي ياتي تبعا لايضا لعوامل
عديده يتمنى الاوكرانيين تحقيقا من خلال
صمود في هذه المنطقه وهذا تابع لصمود كييف
وسومي وايضا المدن الاخرى التي لم يستطع
القوات الروسيه اقتحامها او او التقدم
داخلها هذا العامل الاول العامل الثاني لا
تريد القياده السياسيه الاوكرانيه منح
الروس اي انتصار حتى لو كان هذا الانتصار
رمزي نظرا لما يعني ذلك من ارتفاع
المعنويات القوات الروسيه وربما يتسبب هذا
في هزيمه معنويه نفسيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
الامر الاخر سيدتي ان تمت السيطره على على
على باق موت من قوى القوات الروسيه تريد
اوكرانيا ان يكون هذا الانتصار مكلفا
ومرهقا وباهضا ومستنزفا ايضا للقوات
الروسيه سواء كان على صعيد القوه البشريه
او على صعيد المعدات وايضا هنالك عامل اخر
مهم جدا وهي ان القوات الاوكرانيه ترمي من
خلال صمودها في هذه المنطقه الى مبادله
الوقت بالارض الان القوات الاوكرانيه تريد
كسب المزيد من الوقت في استنزاف القوات
الروسيه تحذيرا لما بعد باك موت وايضا
تحذيرا للهجوم المضاد واستنظارا وانتظارا
لوصول المعدات العسكريه سواء كانت
الدبابات او صواريخ او المعدات الاخرى
وايضا عوده المقاتلين الذين يتدربون في
الولايات المتحده وفي مختلف دول اوروبا
الى الساحه القتال الاوكرانيه وبالتالي
الزج في قوات طازجه ومعدات جديده
لمجابهه القوات الروسيه العامل الخامس
والاخير هو انه اذا انكشف خط الدفاع
الثاني وسقطت باكموت فان خط الدفاع الثالث
المتمثل في سلوفيا
والمناطق المحيطه بها سينكشف للقوات
الروسيه وبالتالي سيكون هنالك مجابهه
وتواجه فيما بين القوات الروسيه وما بين
قوات خط الدفاع الثالث وهذا من شانه ان
تمت السيطره على هذا الخط ان ينهي معركه
الدومباس بنعمتها ولكن يبدو ان هذا في
الوقت الحاضر صعب المنال سيدتي شكرا لك
على المشاركه معنا في العربيه 360 اللواء
محمد الثلجي المحلل العسكري كنت معي من
عمان
[موسيقى]
نفى البيت الابيض صحه التقارير التي تشير
الى التوصل لاتفاق تبادل السجناء مع ايران
ووصفها بالكاذبان ذلك بعد ان اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الايراني توصل الاتفاق المبدئي
لتبادل السجناء مع واشنطن اذ قال ان طهران
تسعى لتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق في اسرع وقت
وكانت مصادر العربيه اكدت وجود صفقه بين
واشنطن وطهران تتضمن اطلاق ايران ثلاث
رهائن امريكيين مقابل افراج واشنطن عن
اموال لطهران مجمده في العراق واليابان
وكوريا
في العربيه 360 متابع كتل برلمانيه تونسيه
تؤيد وعوده العلاقات مع سوريا على امل كشف
ملف تسفير التونسيين لبؤر الارهاب ومحاسبه
المتورطين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وسط توتر المتصاعد مع
الولايات المتحده بسبب التايوان اعلنت
الصين تعيين الجنرال لتشانك فو والمدرج
على قوائم العقبات الامريكيه وزيرا للدفاع
ما اثار التساؤلات حول مغزى الخطوه
الصينيه
[موسيقى]
ليشنكو وزير الدفاع الصيني الجديد عهد قد
ينبئ بتوترات مع الولايات المتحده
صحيح انه يطابق الصفات المفترضه للحزب
الشيوعي الصيني وحظي بموافقه اعلى هيئه
تشريعيه في الصين لكنه مدرج في قائمه
العقوبه الامريكيه منذ عام 2018
حيث تتهمه واشنطن بالتعاون العسكري مع
موسكو حينما كان يتراس مديريه الاسلحه
علما بانه شغل منصب رئيس قسم تطوير
المعدات وقاد قوه الدعم الاستراتيجي للجيش
الصيني وامضى ثلاثه عقود من الزمن في مركز
شيت شانغ لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه ما يعني
ان الصعود ليشانغ فو يعكس تطورا غير مسبوق
لمؤسسه الفضاء
اذ ستواصل بكين منحل اولويه للفضاء في
اجنده ولايه
الثالثه وسيمثل وجود وزير الدفاع الجديد
عمل المحفزا لاستحداث تكنولوجيات قتاليه
ينافس بها امريكا
عسكره بحر الصين الجنوبيه مستمره من جانب
الصين التي تواصل تعزيز قواتها الموجوده
هناك تقرير لصحيفه
عسكريه اضافيه في الجزر والشعاب المرجانيه
هناك جعل الصين قوه بحريه في المنطقه
المطله على عده دول في جنوب شرق اسيا
البحر المتنازع عليه محاط بالصين وتايوان
ودول اسيويه اخرى لكن بكين تطالب بكل
البحر تقريبا رغم قرار محكمه دوليه عام
2016 قال ان المطالبات الصينيه بحقوق
تاريخيه في البحر ليس لها اي اساس قانونيه
ومع تعهد الصين عبر رئيسها لنظيره
الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما بعدم عسكره
بحر الصين الجنوبي الا ان الصين حولت هذه
الشعاب المرجانيه الى جزر اصطناعيه كما
نتابع في الصور وبعدها بعام الجزر
المستحدثه باتت شكرا لعدد من القوات
والقواعد العسكريه التي تضم صواريخ وانظمه
رادار ومطارا ونظام دفاع جوي متكامل
بامكانه ان يطالع جميع دول المنطقه خلال
الاشهر الاخيره حافظت سفن عسكريه امريكيه
على وجود لها في هذه المنطقه رغم محاولات
الاحتكاك التي تعرضت لها من سفن ومقاتلات
صينيه وعلى الجانب الاقتصادي تمر من خلال
المنطقه تريليونات والدولارات من التجاره
الدوليه التي باتت محاصره بين الجزر
الصناعيه الصينيه من الجانبين وبين جزر
سبارتلي وجزر باراسيل
قبل ان نذهب الى ضيفنا نذكر بهذا الخبر
العاجل مراسل العربيه في ليبيا يقول بان
اشتباكات عنيفه في تاجراء شرق العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس اذا حسب مراسل العربيه
هناك اشتباكات عنيفه في تاجوراء شرق
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس ساذهب الان الى
ضيفنا الصحفي نادي
نادر اهلا بك معنا ما هي الرساله التي تود
الصين ارسالها بتعيين وزير الدفاع وهو
عليه عقوبات ولمن هذه الرساله
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
هذا يعني تعيين هو حسب يعني قدرات وخبرات
الجنرال نفسها ويعني لا علاقه لاشاره الى
اي دوله لا يستهدف الى اي دوله اخرى
وكذلك الصين يعني
لا يحق للولايات المتحده الفرد العقوبات
يعني
الصين
الصينيين في السبب يعني تعاونها مع روسيا
يعني ان هذا التعاون يعني قائم بين
الدولتين سياده المستقله وهذا لا يستحدف
ولكن استزداد انت تعلم بانه الصين مقبله
على توترات وهناك الكثير من الملفات التي
هناك فيها تصعيد خاصه مع الولايات المتحده
موضوع تايوان يعني الا تخشوا الصين من عدم
قدره هذا الوزير من التحرك بسبب هذه
العقوبات وهو المكلف بمواجهه مثل هذه
التحديات وخاصه ملف تايوان
[موسيقى]
اسمح لي ان تبقى معي سنذهب لمتابعه موضوع
مسلسل التوتر هناك في بحر الصين حيث هناك
غواصات نوويه ستجوب المحيط الهادئ قريبا
اثر صفقه ثلاثيه بين كل من استراليا من
طرف وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده من طرف
اخر وبالتاكيد كانت الصين اول المتحفظين
نتابع ومن ثم نعود الى ضيفنا
[موسيقى]
صفقه ثلاثيه ستغير الوجود العسكريه في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ وتجلب اليها غواصات
بالدفع النووي
الاتفاق الثلاثي بين كل من استراليا
والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا سيؤمن
لكامبيرا خمس غواصات نوويه خلال العقد
القادم من طراز يو اس اس فرجينيا
والغواصات البريطانيه الهجوميه وما يميزها
هو صعوبه الرصدها وامكانيه السفر لمسافات
طويله بالاضافه لقدرتها على حمل الصواريخ
عابره للقارات
الصفقه جزء من تحالف اوكوس الثلاثي
الهاتفي الى تشارك التكنولوجيا العسكريه
والذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يضم الدول السابقه
تحالف جاء عام 2021 كانت فعلا على نشاط
الصين المتنامي في المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ
اتفاقيه اوكوس تدور حول المستقبل كما انها
تطفي طابعا رسميا للقيم والمصالح المشتركه
لدولنا الثلاث
اعتبرت المشروع الجديد خطيرا هادفا الى
حصارها رد فعل مشابه لاعلان تحالف اوكوس
عندما ادانت الخارجيه الصينيه التصدير
التكنولوجيا النوويه الامريكيه الا ان
كبرى دول اسيا كانت قد اعلنت عن زياده
بنسبه
7.2% من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه لعام 2023
لتكون اكبر زياده منذ العام 2019
اذا عمر العربيه
مره جديده اذهب الى ضيفنا الصحفي نادي
الرونجم من بكين طبعا هناك تحركات من قبل
استراليا من قبل الولايات المتحده
ولكن ايضا نعود الى موضوع عسكره بحر الصين
من قبل الصين هل هذا مؤشر بانه يبدو موضوع
تايوان لن يحل سلميا على الرغم من ان
الصين دائما تتحدث بانها تريد حل هذا
الموضوع سلميا هل اصبح
الخيار العسكري هو الذي سيستعيد تايوان
الى الصين
اعتقد هذا يتوقف على السلوك
الانفصاليين في التايبان وكذلك القوه
داعمه لها اذا كان يعني يتمسكون بمبدا
الواحد
سيكون التوحيد السلمي بالطبع يعني ولكن
اذا كان مسر على
الاعلان استقلال او الفصل
هذا سيدفع المنطقه الى يعني مواجهه
الخطيره فالسين ستتخذ في ذلك الحين ستتخذ
الى الاتخاذ الجميع والاجراءات لمعي فصل
فلذلك فقلت هذا يتعل حدا
يتوقف على السلوك الانفصاليين في تايلاند
وكذلك الدول
الخارجه الداعمه له
يعني اذا كل هذه الاستعدادات التي نشهدها
من طرف الصين لا توشي باي تحرك عسكري قريب
طبعا يعني
الجنوبي من قبل الولايات المتحده
يكون بها السن هو بناء والمنشات المدنيه
وبعد المنشات الدفاعيه يعني
للدفاع الضروريه للدفاع عن يعني هذه الجزر
التابعه للصين
مثل ما فعلته بمثابه ما فعلها الولايات
المتحده في مثلا في جزر هاوي هو كذلك
الجزر الكثير في المحيط الهادئه
والحجم
العسكريه الصيني اقل من الحجم المنشات
الامريكيه في عهد الجزر بالكثير فلذلك
يعني لا توجد ما يسمى بعسكره البحر الصيني
الجنوبي ثم كما قلت
التوحيد والسلمي هو يعني خيار الاول
للبلاد هو حدث يسوق لصالح الجميع شكرا لك
على المشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]
اعلن الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد على النيابه
عوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع سوريا بعد
ان قطعت منذ عام 20 اثناء عشر عده كتل
برلمانيه تونسيه ايدت عوده العلاقات على
امل لفتح ارشيف ملف تسفير تونسيين الى بؤر
التوتر في سوريا للقتال في صفوف تنظيم
داعش وكان قد تم تحويله على العريض رئيس
الوزراء الاسبق التابع لحركه النهضه
الاخوانيه الى القضاء في ذات الملف بعد ان
نشطت عمليات التسفير خلال فتره حكم الحركه
في تونس
رجحت مصادر مطلعه ان تصدر الحكومه
الامريكيه اعلانا جوهريا لدعم الودائع في
بنك سيليكون فالي الذي انهار لمنع اتساع
نطاق التداعيات ووفق المصادر فان مسؤوليه
اداره بعيدا عملوا على تقييم تداعيات
الانهيار وهو الاكبر منذ الازمه الماليه
لعام 2008
تتقاطع هذه الاخبار مع اخرى تتواتر عن ان
مؤسسه التامين على الودائع الفيدراليه
والاحتياطي الفيدراليه رسائل صندوق يسمح
بدعم المزيد من الودائع في البنوك التي قد
تواجه مشاكل بعد انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
وقد ناقش المنظمون انشاء شركه ذاتي اغراض
خاصه بحسب مصادر وكاله
المذيعين ياتي ذلك بعد القلق بشان صحه
البنوك الاصغر التي تركز على شركات راس
المال المغامر والشركات الناشئه
كارثه المصرفيه قد تطال البنوك الامريكيه
في حال لم تقدم اداره الرئيس جو بايدن حلا
في اسرع وقت بدات مع ازمه افلاس بنك
سيليكون فالي والتي تعد الاكبر منذ الازمه
الماليه العالميه عام 2008
ازمه اس في بي ادت الى هلع بين المودعين
في البنك ليتجهوا الى سحب اموالهم دفعه
واحده بينما اصول البنك لا تكفي لتغطيه
جميع الودائع فالمبالغ التي تكون ادنى من
250 الف دولار يغطيها تامين للسحب الفوري
من قبل مؤسسه تامين الوداع الفيدراليه
لتبقى بقيه المبالغ في البنك
ضغط المودعين على سيليكون فالي ادى الى
انهياره ما دفع الحكومه لاغلاقه بجميع
فروعه والاتجاه الى ايجاد حل لانقاذ اموال
المودعين
الخوف الاكبر ان تنتقل العدوى الى بنوك
اخرى مشابهه لسليكون غالي ما قد يؤدي الى
كارثه مصرفيه حقيقيه ونزيف في تمويل قطاع
التكنولوجيا والشركات الناشئه
مصادر من البيت الابيض اكدت ان مسؤول
اداره بايدن يقيمون تداعيات انهيار البنك
تجنبا لتاثير افلاس اس في بي على بقيه
البنوك
يبقى الحل معلقا حتى يوم الاثنين الذي
يجتمع خلاله البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي
من دبي ينضم الى محرر الشؤون الاقتصاديه
في قناه العربيه زميل عباده عباده اهلا بك
معنا طبعا اليوم كل المخاوف تنصب حول ما
اذا سيكون بنك سيليكون فالي يعني
افلاس او لمشاكل لدى بنوك اخرى الى اي حد
هذا الامر من الممكن ان يحصل
هذا ميسون طبعا هذا هو السؤال الجوهري
وهناك ساعات قليله قبل افتتاح الاسواق
الامريكيه في صباح الاثنين فبالتالي هذه
الساعات مهمه جدا لانه على السلطات
التنظيميه ان تجد حلا لهذا البنك قبل ان
تفتتح الاسواق لانه هناك سيناريو من اثنين
اما ان يذهب هذا البنك الى التصفيات
فبالتالي مصير الودائع تتوزع ما بين
الودائع الصغيره يعني 250 الف دولار واقل
او اقل من ذلك هذه تضمنها
مؤسسه الضمان الودائع الفتاليه اما
المبالغ الاكبر من ذلك هذه سيكون مصيرها
يعني ستنتظر التصفيه او انه صناديق التحوط
تشتريها بسعر مخصوم وتنتظر
نتيجه التصفيه النهائيه لترى ما يتم
تعويضه من هذه المبالغ فبالتالي يعني هذا
هذه هي المساله
الكبرى الاساسيه التي تبحث فيها السلطات
طبعا كما ذكرت تقريبا قبل قليل هناك بحث
ما بين مؤسسه الضمان الودائع
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
اتى مستثمر
واشترى هذا البنك يعني بدا الحديث الان
بانه يبدو ايلون ماسك ليس ببعيد عن هذه
الفكره هناك احاديث ايضا عن شركات موجوده
هنا في الامارات الممكن ان تفكر تشتري في
بريطانيا هذا الفرع في بريطانيا هل شراء
مستثمر لهذا البنك يحل الازمه
المشكله انه الازمه وقعت ضغطه يعني اول ما
بدات اشارات او رد بلاك انه هناك مشكله
كان يوم الاربعاء
يعني كان الوقت ضيق جدا يوم الخميس كانت
هناك طلبات سحوبات هائله 40 مليار دولار
لم يكن هناك وقت لتدبر الامر
لحقيقه تقييم البنك في هذا الوقت صعب
مساله صعبه لانه اي مستثمر يحتاج الى
تقييم واقعي ان يعرف ماذا في الدفاتر
ليتوصل الى تقييم واقعي ولكن طبعا اذا وجد
مستثمر يستطيع ان يشتري البنك فبالتالي
يتكفل بمعالجه مساله ودائع هذا يهدئ
القطاع ككل لانه نحن الان نتحدث عن ثلاثه
مستويات للمشكله مستوى يتعلق
يعني
او الامتداد هذه الازمه الى بنوك اخرى هذه
واحده لانه
يمكن ان تحدث ازمه ثقه فبالتالي
المودعون يهرع بالسداد وداعيه من جميع
البنوك التي يظنون ان فيها مشكله هذا
مستوى هناك مشكله اخرى تتعلق بالشركات
الناشئه
بكل الاستثمار بهذا القطاع يعني
راس المال المغامر الذي يستثمر بشركات
التقنيه
وهناك مستوى ثالث يتعلق بالاقتصاد ومعدلات
الفائده فكل ان تبقى معي لنذهب ونتابع ما
هي تداعيات هذه الازمه في الجانب
البريطاني ومن ثم اعود اليك وزير الماليه
البريطاني جريمه هاند قال لشبكه سكاي نيوز
البريطانيه الاخباريه ان انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي يشكل خطرا جسيما على قطاع
التكنولوجيا وعلوم الحياد في البلاد
اعتقد ان اول شيء يجب قوله هو ان محافظ
بنكي انجلترا المركزي قد اوضح تماما انه
لا توجد مخاطر منهجيه على نظامنا المالي
لذلك يجب طمانه الناس على هذا الاساس ولكن
هناك خطر جسيم على تقنيتنا وقطاعات علوم
الحياه والعديد منها يتعامل مع هذا البنك
الذي لم يسمع به معظم الناس
اذا في بريطانيا هناك تخوف على قطاع
البنوك كما تحدث الوزير على قطاع
التكنولوجيا عذرا هل حقيقه هناك مخاوف من
تاثير ذلك على قطاع التكنولوجيا وعلى
المستثمرين وخاصه في منطقتنا عباده لانه
هناك استثمار كبير بهذا القطاع
نعم هذه مساله اساسيه جدا لانه شركات
ستارت يعني لها طبيعه خاصه انها تحرق
الكثير من الكاش في يعني في في عملياتها
فبالتالي هي بحاجه لراس مال وهناك بنوك
متخصصه لابد ان تمولها فاذا وقع هذا البنك
هناك شركات كثيره تعتمد على هذا البنك في
تمويل عملياتها اذا توقف هذا البنك عليها
ان تنتظر لوقت طويل لتسترد ودائعها في حال
لم يتم الاستحواذ عليهم بنك اخر فهذه
الشركات ستعاني ماليا وبالتالي تحتاج
الفنشر كابتنز او الصناديق راس الم
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه تانز اوف اسرائيل
الى ان الاحتجاجات يتم تمويلها وتنظيمها
بملايين الدولارات عن طريق مراكز تنسيق
تنشر المتظاهرين بطريقه منظمه
اعلن حداد واضراب تجاري في مدينه نابلس
عقب مقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي واصابه اخر تم اعتقاله لاحقا
الجيش الاسرائيلي وصف العمليه بالحازمه
والدقيقه باستهدافه لمن قال انهم اطلقوا
النار على موقع للجيش فيما تبنت مجموعه
عرين الاسود الهجوم المسلح واعلنت مقتله
ثلاثه من افرادها
هنا قتلت اسرائيل ثلاثه فلسطينيين واعتقلت
رابعا في عمليه قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الفلسطينيين الاربعه اطلقوا النار على
نقطه للجيش الاسرائيلي صباحا فقتل ثلاثه
منهم واصيب رابع تم اعتقاله لاحقا وبحسب
المصادر الفلسطينيه فان الاربعه ينتمون
الى تنظيم عرين الاسود في مدينه نابلس
وكانوا في طريقهم لاطلاق النار على نقطه
عسكريه اسرائيليه بين قريتي جيت وصار غرب
نابلس مشهد بات يتكرر يوميا تقريبا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه حداد واضرار يشل
الحركه التجاريه في المدن الفلسطينيه عقب
مقتل فلسطينيين فقد قتل منذ بدايه العام
الحالي برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من
ثمانين فلسطينيه
من مدينه نابلس شمال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
خالد القاسم العربي
في العربيه 360 اوكرانيا ستصبح بانديرا
وروسيا ستنقلب الى موسكوبيا على الاقل في
ذهن اصحاب التسميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان تاسيس ناقل جوي جديد
بمسمى طيران الرياض للمساهمه في تطوير
قطاع النقل الجوي وتهدف شركه طيران الرياض
لاطلاق رحله تصل لاكثر من 100 وجهه حول
العالم بحلول العام 2030 وستكون الشركه
مملوكه بالكامل لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات انعجاف عانت فيها السينما
العالميه من تراجع في كل شيء لان محركها
الاول الجمهور غاب عن مقاعده يعود حفل
الاوسكار هذا العام بزخم كبير للاحتفال
اولا بافلام النجحت في اعاده شغف الجمهور
للسينما والاحتفال ثانيا بنجوم في مختلف
الفئات قدموا اداء مذهلا هذا العام ما جعل
المنافسه على بعض الجوائز عصيه على التوقع
نتابع
جوائز اوسكار لعام 2023
الفيلم الكوميدي افري ثنج ايفري
مرشح لاحدى عشره جائزه
من الافلام المرشحه
المنافسه حاميه في فئه افضل ممثل بين
براندن فريزر عن ذويلد
[موسيقى]
المرشح الابرز لجائزه افضل ممثل مساعد من
المتوقع ان يحظى بها كيهوكوان عن فيلم
جائزه افضل ممثله تتركز المنافسه فيها بين
كيت بلانشيت عن دورها في تار
وميشيليو بطله فيلم
التي قد تصبح اول اسيويه تحصل على اللقب
عن هذه الفئه
المنظمون ياملون ان تساهم الحفله في طي
صفحه صفعه الشهيره التي عكرت صفوه امسيه
العام المنصرف
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينضم الينا النقد الفني طارق
الشناوي لنبدا استاذ طارق من هذه الصوره
التي انتهت منها التقرير وهو موضوع الصفحه
ماذا ستفعل الاكاديميه هذه السنه لمحو ما
حصل في السنه الماضيه البعض يعتبر العار
الذي حصل على المسرح في السنه الماضيه
عموما في كل حفل سواء كان اوسكار او غيره
دائما هناك شيء يسرق الكاميرا ربما كانت
سرقه الكاميرا في الاوسكار الماضي اللي هو
94 كان كانت السرقه يعني ثقيله على النفس
لكن مؤكد هنكتشف وهنرى بعد ساعات لانه هو
تقريبا بتوقيت السعوديه الساعه 3:00 الفجر
هنرى شيء يثق الكاميرا بعيدا عن من حصل
على الجائزه او من غضب لانه لم يحصل لازم
حاجه كل مهرجان او كل مسابقه لان الاوسكار
مسابقه كبيره لازم تحصل حاجه طبعا المميزه
السنه لن يكون سجاده حمراء ستكون سجاده
بيج
لنعود استس طارق لموضوع لموضوع الافلام
الان هل التعاطف هذه السنه لن يذهب الى
العمل الابداعي
التفاصيل الفنيه الدقيقه بل سيذهب للافلام
التي استطاعت استعاده الروحيه للسينما بعد
سنوات لايجاف مع كورونا
طبعا السنه دي في اكتر من فيلم زي افاتار
مثلا زي توب جن وغيره جابوا ايرادات ضخمه
جدا لكن مؤكد انه الانحياز
للفن له قيم جماليه طبعا لا يعني انه
افاتار مثلا فيلم اقل جمالا او انه يخاصم
بالعكس مليء بالتفاصيل لكن في كل الاحوال
السنه دي المسابقه قويه لانه بعد عامين من
كورونا والخوف من كورونا
نهضه السينما مجددا وبقى في ضخ اموال لانه
بقى فيه شاشات وجمهور اللي هو عصب الحياه
السينمائيه عدا مجددا بقوه فانا بعتقد ان
السنه دي العدد كبير العدد الافلام
المرشحه
والفروق ليست كبيره يعني 11
انا بشوف انه يمكن كل شيء كل مكان في كل
مكان مره واحده اتصور انه احتمال كبير هو
اللي يحظى يليه افاتار يحظى بالجائزه له
افاتار والف ربما يبقى بطل الفيلم هو
جائزه احسن لممثل مثلا بالنسبه لي ايضا
هناك كبير بالنسبه للممثلات بين كاتب
لعنشات بين ايضا
يعني هذه المره اذا نالتها يعني
امر نادر تكون اول ممثله تنال هذا العدد
من النجمات صحيح
انا اعتقد انه كيد بلانشت هي الاقرب بعد
ساعات للحصول على الجائزه وهي طبعا
ممثله كبيره
واظل ممكن يبقى الرهان عليها اكبر
وبالنسبه
التي جسدت التي جسدت دور
اه لكن انا شايف انه اكيد بلانشيت هي اللي
هتبقى فرصتها اكبر هذا العام في كل
الاحوال التصويت اللي هو بيتم في
الاكاديميه ما نقدرش نقول انها لجنه حكيم
بتختار بشكل مباشر الافضل لكنها تصويت
والتصويت او الديمقراطيه حتى في المطلق مش
بالضروره بتجيب افضل النتائج لكن هي تظل
هي افضل الحلول يعني لان البديل سيء لكن
هي في النهايه هو تصويت والتصويت لا يعني
انه بيذهب ميه في الميه للافضل شكرا لك
طارق الشناوي عناق الفني كنت معي من
القاهره وطبعا يعني ساعات قصيره تفصلنا عن
هذا الحفل الكبير وغدا صباحا يعني تكون كل
النتائج ايضا واضحه اكثر شكرا لك في تصريح
اليوم في العربيه 360 نقترح ان يكون اسمها
الجديد بانديرا هذا هو الاسم الذي يقترحه
رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي اوكرانيا
في اشاره لاستيفان بانديرا وهو احد
الاوكرانيين الذين تعاونوا مع النازيين في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
على وصم اوكرانيا بالعلاقه مع النازيين
بعد ان اقترح الرئيس الاوكراني تغيير رسم
روسيا الى موسكوبيا وهي دوله من القرون
الوسطى كانت تدمر روسيا واوكرانيا معا
طبعا اقتراح زالنسكي كان غرضه السخريه من
روسيا والتبرير ما تعتبره اوكرانيا عدوانا
على اراضيها
اما فيديو اليوم فهو من كاليفورنيا يحلم
كثيرون بالسكن على نهر او بحيره لكن من
صور هذا الفيديو بالتاكيد على استعداد ان
يبادل سكنه ولو باخر في وسط الصحراء
[موسيقى]
اما سوره اليوم فهي من دونيتسكي
الاوكرانيه عادت لانا لتتفقد منزلها بعد
قصفه عادت بيد المصابه لتتفقد كيف عبثت
قذيفه بحياتها تكافح الجدران بما تحمله من
ذكريات كي تبقى صامدات لكنها بالتاكيد لن
تستطيع امام الانفجار القادم خسر المنزل
الكثير خسر كل شيء تقريبا لكنه كسب شيئا
واحدا المزيد من النوافذ نوافذ اجباريه
خلفتها قوه الانفجار
[موسيقى]
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي العربيه 360 ولكن
دائما اخبار العربيه وملفات جديده مستمره
والان ما اخبار الساعه والليله مع الزميله
رشا مساء الخير رشا مساء الخير ملك اليوم
في اخبار الساعه لدينا ابراز للتقارير
الصحفيه التي تتحدث عن الخلاف ما بين
واشنطن حول اداره العملات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا لدينا ايضا
ينقلب على من كان رئيسي يوما ويوجه له
سهام الانتقاد اللاذعه ولدينا ايضا متابعه
لتداعيات الاقتصاديه لسقوط بنك سيليكون
طبعا سنتابعك شكرا شكرا